nos encontramos en la población de jujuy
o una ciudad a 30 km de la ciudad de
heart if que fue atacada constantemente
por las tropas rusas durante los días
más difíciles no alcanzaron a entrar
aquí pero sí estuvieron en los límites
de la ciudadela bombardeaban
permanentemente las versiones de quienes
vivieron aquí en esos tiempos
cuentan que estuvieron todo el tiempo en
los sótanos con muy poca comida vivían
prácticamente bajo el terror y
escondidos todo el tiempo de nuevo
cuando las tropas ucraniana lograron
retirar las tropas rusas de estos
sectores la vida volvió a la normalidad
pero los ataques continuaron el pasado
29 de junio hubo un gran ataque a pocos
metros de aquí en la estación de
autobuses donde murieron seis personas
pero cuentan las autoridades que el
ritmo de estos ataques de las fuerzas
rusas ha venido disminuyendo en los
últimos días y lo que vemos es de cierta
manera como la población ha regresado y
ha vuelto
vivir un poco también esto se ve en cada
una de las ciudades donde la presión de
los ataques rusos bajan esto en esta
provincia de jarque